bonjour Nathalie Delattre merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous de nous accompagner
pendant cette première demi-heure élite
la Gironde du groupe Rassemblement
démocratique sociale européen
vice-présidente du Sénat et à l'origine
de cette proposition dont on va parler
pour soutenir les élus agressés on va en
parler longuement tout à l'heure mais
d'abord un mot puisque le Sénat va voter
cet après-midi le budget de la Sécurité
sociale dans lequel il a inscrit une
nouvelle fois j'ai envie de dire un
report de l'âge de départ à 64 ans pour
vous c'est pas la bonne méthode non
effectivement notre groupe à l'habitude
de s'abstenir de voter contre cet
amendement non pas sur l'amendement en
lui-même mais sur la méthode parce que
effectivement nous n'avons pas à
simplement exposer la problématique des
retraites du report de la pénibilité en
deux minutes de présentation
d'amendement d'amendements et deux
minutes d'explication de vote en cas
nous sommes d'accord avec l'agenda qui a
été présenté à savoir le début d'année
pour pouvoir ouvrir cette question à
part entière qui va engager les
générations futures et répondre aux
interrogations aux préoccupations des
Français donc nous sommes pour un long
débat et non pas simplement si le
gouvernement inscrit l'âge de départ
parce que ce qui semble être le cas là
vous voterez
alors nous sommes plus en tout cas en ce
qui me concerne pour une retraite
partout qui va prendre en compte la
pénibilité mais j'attends j'attends
effectivement le fruit des discussions
des réflexions qui va se passer pour
pouvoir me prononcer sur le texte qui
émanera effectivement de cette
concertation on va parler des élus lundi
va s'ouvrir le Congrès des mers qui va
durer une semaine les élus locaux qui
sont de plus en plus victimes
d'agression vous êtes à l'origine d'un
texte qui vise allez soutenir contre
cela notre journaliste parlementaire
alex pusard va nous le détailler
[Musique]
bonjour Oriane bonjour Nathalie de la
proposition de la Nathalie Delattre
intervient une période où les violences
faites aux élus sont en hausse du
ministère de l'Intérieur en 2021 il y a
eu 162 parlementaires victimes
d'agression physique et 602 mères ou
adjoints également victimes d'agression
ce qui représente une hausse de 47% par
rapport à 2020 même si 2020 a été une
année plutôt calme avec le covid il y a
quand même une hausse significative de
ces violences faites aux élus ces
dernières années en ce qui concerne les
outrages en 2021 419 outrages d'élus ont
été recensés à ce qui représente une
hausse de 30% alors pour protéger
davantage nos élus votre proposition de
loi Nathalie Delatte permet à trois
associations d'élus de se porter partie
civiles dans ses affaires il s'agit de
l'AMF l'Association des maires de France
l'ADF pour les départements et puis
région de France auparavant seuls les
associations départementales de la MF en
avait la possibilité ce texte élargit
également la liste des infractions
pouvant permettre à ces associations de
se porter civile en plus des injures
outras diffamation menaces elles
pourront le faire en cas de l'exposition
de l'élu à un risque ou de dégradation
de ses biens et c'est une promotion de
Alex qui s'ajoute à d'autres mesures
voter ces dernières années pour protéger
les élus et oui on peut citer la loi
engagement et proximité de 2019 qui
avait sécurisé la prise en charge de la
protection fonctionnelle de l'élu en cas
de violence avec l'obligation pour la
collectivité de souscrire à un contrat
d'assurance et pour les petites communes
les frais de protection de l'élu comme
par exemple les frais d'avocats sont
compensés entièrement par l'État et le
mois dernier dans le cadre de l'examen
du projet loi locmin d'orientation et de
programmation du ministère de
l'Intérieur examen au Sénat et bien la
majorité sénatoriale a augmenté la peine
encourue en cas de violence sur un élu
une peine augmentée à 50 prisons et
75000 euros d'amende c'est le quantum de
Pen par exemple pour les violences sur
les forces de l'ordre et ce texte-là est
actuellement en cours d'examen à
l'Assemblée nationale Nathalie Delatte
concrètement en quoi ce texte va changer
les choses va de mieux protéger nos élus
alors simplement pour revenir sur un des
informations que vous donnez ce texte
esthétiquement a été travaillé je l'ai
travaillé à l'origine avec l'Association
des maires de France l'Association des
départements de France et les régions de
France mais par une co-construction du
texte entre la Commission et le
gouvernement nous allons étendre cette
possibilité à l'ensemble des
associations représentant les élus et je
pense notamment à l'Association des
Maires Ruraux de France pour
effectivement accompagner les élus vous
avez dit une augmentation de 50% des
agressions
celle connue parce que encore trop peu
d'élus portent plainte ils vont au bout
effectivement de la procédure donc
le fait d'inclure les associations à
leur côté c'est la possibilité d'aller
et effectivement dans cette démarche et
plus loin dans cette démarche et de
pouvoir aujourd'hui quand vous une
agression physique parce que certes vous
avez noté les outrages mais ce que l'on
a c'est de plus en plus d'agressions
physiques
et bien c'est de pouvoir aboutir à une
procédure judiciaire et éviter les
classements sans suite parce que
malheureusement encore trop peu souvent
n'avons même pas de rappel à la loi ou
de mesures d'éloignement de la commune
donc voilà ça va permettre les éviter
les classements
nationales se portent partie civiles
évidemment le parquet va être beaucoup
plus attentif la chaîne judiciaire va
être beaucoup plus attentive et puis les
moyens vont être donnés par ces
associations pour qu'il y ait des
relances pour effectivement le dossier
puisse puisse prospérer parce que les
élus et les élus mais les élus aussi
s'autocensure au nom d'une
responsabilité coûte que coûte non il
faut cesser il n'y a aucune
tous les matins se lèvent pour voir
comment ils vont améliorer la vie de
leur citoyens au quotidien moi j'étais
ce week-end malheureusement j'entérais
le meilleur ami de mon fils c'est le
maire qui a pris le décès de leur fils
aux parents qui a assisté à des
incarcération c'est-à-dire que tous les
jours ces mères font face à des
problématiques et de plus en plus à des
insultes ou des agressions c'est
inadmissible inadmissible donc il faut
effectivement pouvoir les accompagner
comment vous expliquer cette flambée de
violence d'agression contre nos élus
écoute je crois que voilà c'est vrai que
les gens ont de plus en plus de mal à
gérer leurs frustration le nom c'est
vrai que un élu va essayer de faire en
sorte que on sera biboche avec son
voisin même si on déteste son voisin il
faut bien vivre à côté oui effectivement
l'état instruit
un permis de construire et et à des
préconisations lourdes c'est le maire
qui va expliquer c'est vrai que le
quotidien est expliqué par le maire et
il ne doit pas annoncer que les bonnes
nouvelles donc
les Français réagissent de plus en plus
mal vis-à-vis de cela et puis on le sait
un des amours de la politique en tout
cas de la classe politique même
vis-à-vis de ces élus locaux des mères
qui étaient les élus préférés des
français mais on voit bien dans les
sondages que même la cote des élus
locaux sérum malheureusement parce que
aujourd'hui c'est tous pourris tous
pareils donc la crise d'évocation
éphémère aussi elle s'explique par cette
violence bien sûr bien sûr parce que moi
je le vois au quotidien nous recevons en
tant que sénateur mais les élus locaux
aussi enfin parlementaires des mails
d'insultes
souvent
signé d'un pseudonyme ou c'est vrai que
les gens manquent beaucoup de courage
mais aussi lire au quotidien des mails
d'insultes des courriers d'insultes
c'est vrai que ça s'appelait le moral
alors que on est là pour
l'intérêt général et faire en sorte que
notre société fonctionne au mieux alors
je le disais à la majorité du Sénat a
inscrit dans la loi Love Me une
augmentation des peines pour les
violences faites aux élus est-ce que
vous souhaitez que l'Assemblée nationale
conserve cette peine augmenter ce que
c'est proportionné 50 prisons 75000
euros d'amende en cas de violence contre
un élu parce que je pense que il faut
que les Français se rendent compte de ce
qu'ils font c'est vrai que bon il faut
dire qu'on a le mauvais exemple parce
que quand dans des médias on peut se
retrouver à un parlementaire insulté
évidemment après ça déverrouille tout
donc oui je pense qu'il faut que les
Français puissent se rendre compte que
ça coûte cher d'insulter la République
justement on va évoquer cette affaire en
ce moment la faire Boyard Hanouna le
présentateur de la chaîne C8 qui a
insulté Louis Boyard le député la France
insoumise sur son plateau car il
critiquait Vincent Bolloré le
propriétaire de la chaîne Louis Boyard a
porté plainte hier pour injure public
envers une personne chargée d'une
mission de service public est-ce que
dans ce cas-là vous souhaitez que la
justice soit au rendez-vous bien sûr
on ne peut pas tout faire tout n'est pas
permis on peut pas rire de tout on ne
peut pas tout évoquer sans une certaine
gravité il faut remettre au coeur de
notre société des valeurs des enjeux des
perspectives alors je suis
insultes tout à fait je suis loin de
partager les idées de mon collègue
parlementaire et les filles mais là je
lui adresse vraiment mon plein et entier
soutien dans cette plainte et
cette décision d'aller jusqu'au bout de
de la reconnaissance de ses insultes et
de la peine que pourrait encourir
effectivement le présentateur et la
chaîne de télé un dernier mot sur votre
proposition de après on va parler du
Congrès des Maires vous avez le soutien
du Sénat vous avez su du gouvernement
aussi oui tout à fait oui oui puisque
nous avons co-construit ce texte
la dgccl la direction des collectivités
locales nous a permis de réécrire ce
texte pour qu'il soit le plus
constitutionnellement parfait même si
nous avions déjà bien travaillé au sein
du Sénat avec les administrateurs la
commission moi j'ai 93 collègues qui ont
cosigné ce texte mais c'était une
volonté très forte du gouvernement de
pouvoir faire avancer ce texte et de
faire en sorte que à l'Assemblée
nationale et puisse être voté à
l'identité vous esp qui rentrent en
vigueur
le temps de faire la navette mais
j'espère que nous arrivons à trouver une
niche assez rapidement du côté de
l'Assemblée nationale parce que c'est
encore une fois un texte important qui
va toucher tous les élus c'est vrai que
nous avons l'esprit de montagne c'était
de de parler des élus locaux mais nous
avons rajouté les parlementaires et les
députés européens aussi
effectivement qui pareil en face à une
augmentation des insultes merci Alex à
tout à l'heure merci l'emploi des
seniors ce sera dans le club dans une
demi-heure on va parler du Congrès des
marges justement puisqu'on parlait des
élus qui s'ouvre lundi qui va durer
toute la semaine hier et Elisabeth borne
était à Marseille à la rencontre des
mers elle a dit qu'elle sera à leur côté
pour traverser les prochains mois qui
s'annoncent difficile vous croyez à
cette promesse elle se sont améliorée
les relations entre les élus et
l'exécutif depuis le début du
quinquennat écouter je pense qu'il y a
pas mal d'annonces pour se faire je
crois qu'il y a toujours une réserve de
la part des élus c'est vrai qu'il y a
des mesures qui sont incomprises
se rappelle la taxe d'habitation
personne n'attendait vraiment la fin de
cette impôt et c'est vrai que l'impact
sur les communes pour l'instant et
compenser mais la CVAE c'est pareil
c'est à dire que
un territoire dynamique qui génère ses
propres ressources va être mis sous la
coupe effectivement de l'État je crois
que c'est ça que les élus la cotisations
soit reportée d'un an oui c'est le bon
curseur où il ne faut pas du tout
qu'elle entre en vigueur ecoutez de
toute manière c'est dans les tuyaux
c'est annoncé donc il faut pouvoir
prendre le temps de réfléchir à la
fiscalité qui lit nos concitoyens et les
communes les services publics
décentralisés les services locaux donc
je crois qu'effectivement il y a
toujours une méfiance de la part du
gouvernement mais ce gouvernement qui
multiplie les annonces mais au-delà des
annonces les actions il faut de le
reconnaître et justement c'est mer parce
que au palais de leur finance qui se
disent inquiets pour leurs capacité
d'agir ils disent voir leur marge de
manœuvre entravée sur le plan financier
notamment ils en appel au Sénat qui
examinent à partir de jeudi le budget
que pouvez-vous faire bah écoutez nous
allons faire ce que nous faisons comme
d'habitude c'est-à-dire amender le texte
nous verrons dans quelle mesure nos
amendements si déclenchement du 49-3 il
y a seront conservés donc tout l'art du
Sénat va être de négocier en permanence
pour faire en sorte que les
collectivités soient protégées parce que
elles ont été durement touchées par les
crises il n'y a pas que nos concitoyens
mais les collectivités et les services
qu'elle rendent et qui permettent à nos
concitoyens qui sont des amortisseurs
sociaux mais aussi financiers quand on
sait que les communes prennent en part
une partie de de l'éducation une partie
des mesures sociales
la cant la crèche c'est à dire des coûts
diminués pour nos concitoyens c'est très
importants l'effort qu'elle concède et
c'est ce que disent les mères qu'on en
demande plus aux collectivités qu'elle
est à vous partager ça oui bien sûr
parce que l'État ne se l'impose pas à
lui-même exemple nous avons dû négocier
ce bouclier tarifaire pour les pour les
communes parce que elles sont les
premières impactées puisque elles ont
les locaux notamment de classe de
crèches de club seniors etc et c'est
vrai que elles étaient impactées de
plein fouet par l'augmentation de
l'énergie il fallait absolument arriver
à trouver des solutions avec le
gouvernement pour pour les protéger et
faire en sorte que les services
continuent et certaines communes qui
augmentent la taxe foncière c'était
encore le cas à Paris ce weekend vous
comprenez c'est mère qui augmente la
taxe foncière écoutez de tout manière
une commune ne peut pas boucler son
budget en déficit contrairement à l'état
donc il n'y a pas 36.000 façons pour
arriver à un équilibre quand on n'a pas
assez de subvention
c'est commune doivent aussi rentrer dans
un gagnant-gagnant c'est à dire que
quand on parle de bouclier tarifaire
énergétique il faut aujourd'hui qu'elle
puisse investir pour que demain elles
aient des économies d'échelle qui
puissent se réaliser je les comprends
parfaitement on va aller voir
l'actualité du côté de chez vous on va à
Bordeaux on retrouve Jefferson des
sports journaliste politique à sud-ouest
bonjour je vais faire ça bon merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous depuis la
Gironde et vous allez parler de
plusieurs sujets avec Nathalie Delattre
vous commencez par la corrida
allez on va commencer par oui les
questions de tradition ce matin Nathalie
Delattre le Sud-Ouest c'est une terre de
corrida le 24 novembre le député des
films brick Caron va présenter sa
proposition de loi pour interdire la
corrida alors est-ce que vous serez aux
côtés des villes taurines et des
aficionados pour défendre la tour
machine àtre oui je le dis sans
détournement bien sûr je suis une
aficionados alors je ne suis pas souvent
dans les arènes malheureusement parce
que j'ai beaucoup de travail mais on me
voit chaque année à La Brède qui est la
place la plus septentrionale de France
en Gironde et je défends effectivement
ces traditions je peux entendre les
les états d'âme de certains mais je
pense que à chaque fois des réponses
sont données par rapport au bien-être
animal
oui on peut toujours surfer sur les pour
les contres bien sûr que de part et
d'autre les arguments sont donnés mais
je pense qu'il faut surtout que l'on est
à l'esprit que nous avons des traditions
des coutumes qui peuvent être revisités
mais elles ne peuvent pas être annihilés
d'un revers de main je crois qu'il faut
savoir respecter chacun et pour
l'interdiction tradition taurine font
partie de la vie de notre sud-ouest et
Sud-Est notamment donc je pense que ce
type de loi est plutôt de nature très
très populiste malheureusement il ne
fait pas avancer ne fait pas avancer les
causes défendues populistes sur les
questions
juste un mot sur le mot populiste ça
veut dire que ça peut faire monter les
populismes ce genre de propositions
je pense que c'est de nature
à mobiliser certains camps politiques
pour dire écoutez nous nous défendons
les traditions ça peut être notamment le
rassemblement national donc je trouve
que
le encore une fois je pense que
le l'objectif de de cette de cette loi
et plus que détourner pardon je vais
faire ça allez-y non on va rester sur
les questions de tradition Oriane et
Delattre avec la chasse la question du
partage de la nature se pose le Sénat a
conduit une mission d'information sur la
sécurisation de la chasse et dans son
rapport du mi-septembre il a écarté une
des propositions des anti-chats à savoir
la généralisation d'un jour sans chasse
le mercredi ou le dimanche est-ce que
vous êtes favorable justement à ce que
nous en reste là et qu'il n'y ait pas de
jour sans chasse oui je écoutais la
présidente de cette mission est dans mon
groupe nous avons particulièrement suivi
puisque chaque semaine elle nous faisait
un reporting sur les auditions et
nous partageons au groupe les
conclusions effectivement de cette
mission d'information qui a fait des
propositions fortes je pense qu'il faut
que
chasseur et citoyens apprennent à se
connaître nous avons besoin des
chasseurs nous avons une recrudescence
notamment des sangliers qui causent de
multiples accidents
et donc effectivement il faut que nous
arrivions à trouver
ce partage de territoire et je ne pense
pas qu'il réside dans le fait qu'il
faille
interdire un jour particulier la chasse
il faut simplement qu'il y ait les bons
signalements c'est à dire quand il y a
une battue mais c'est ce qui est fait
sur l'ensemble du territoire je pense
que les chasseurs ont pris conscience de
de beaucoup de choses et font en sorte
que leur signalisation sur le territoire
se fasse plus facilement pour que nos
comptes citoyens sachent quand une battu
se fait et puis il faut apprendre il y a
des risques dans la nature donc il faut
aussi apprendre à vivre avec ces risques
et je pense que au niveau de la sécurité
nous voyons que les fédérations de
chasse mettent beaucoup beaucoup de
moyens pour former les chasseurs et
sécuriser cette pratique
mais est-ce que vous faites un lien
entre cette volonté d'interdire la
corrida cette volonté d'attaquer aussi
la chasse à la lueur évidemment des
accidents qui se produisent mais ce que
la question de la tradition aujourd'hui
est difficile à défendre est-ce que vous
sentez que certaines valeurs justement
du sud-ouest par notre région sont
aujourd'hui menacées oui bien sûr et
c'est toute la confrontation du monde
urbain du monde rural aussi qui
s'exprime à travers
c'est demande d'interdiction on voit
bien les néo urbains ou les néo-ruraux
qui arrivent et qui souhaitent faire
que l'on entend plus la cloche de
l'église effectivement qui est plus coup
de feu le dimanche matin parce que ça ça
nous réveille etc etc donc on voit bien
et effectivement ce qui peut se jouer
dans les en jeu moi je vois bien avec
les hygiénistes aussi la demande
d'interdiction de l'alcool donc ça nous
touche particulièrement en Gironde avec
la
viticulture donc on voit un monde qui
progresse fait d'interdiction et c'est
vrai que au Sénat notamment nous sommes
un rempart sur ce monde d'interdit mais
d'essayer de trouver des compromis et la
meilleure façon de vivre tous ensemble
dans le respect de nos cultures et de
nos valeurs un dernier sujet beaucoup de
personnes oui une dernière question
politique on parle beaucoup du retour
annoncé d'Adrien catenain ce député
vérifier à l'Assemblée un autre député
va faire son retour dans quelques jours
c'est Grégoire de Fournat ce député
Irène de Gironde est-ce que vous pensez
qu'il a toujours sa place Grégoire de
Fournas à l'Assemblée après son propos
et cette phrase qu'il retourne en
Afrique côté il a été élu
démocratiquement
et en connaissance de cause je pense que
effectivement
nous savons depuis longtemps qu'il
aimait des tweets et des idées racistes
et
je crois qu'il ne m'appartient pas de
savoir si c'est un bien ou un mal qui le
revienne mais
il a été s'il ne démissionne pas il n'a
pas l'intention de le faire il est élu
et c'est un élu du peuple il a eu la
sanction maximum de ce que prévoit le
bureau de
l'Assemblée nationale je ne pense pas
que ça puisse l'empêcher de
prôner des tests racistes demain d'avoir
encore des propos de ce type
malheureusement je crois qu'il faut
plutôt continuer à s'interroger sur le
pourquoi
des
gens comme lui et qui soutiennent ce
type de thèse sont élus c'est vrai qu'il
faut entendre la détresse des Français
sur plusieurs problématiques et pouvoir
travailler sur ces sujets pour faire en
sorte que demain il ne soit pas réélu et
que vous que vous expliquez comment
cette montée du RN et surtout cette
poussée dans des zones géographiques où
il n'était pas présent avant c'est
notamment cas chez vous le RN n'est pas
présent dans l'ouest de la France
comment vous l'expliquez cette poussée
du rassemblement national dans ces zones
une prospérez pas vous savez justement
sur ces propos moi j'ai pas entendu
beaucoup de personnes me dire qu'il
n'avait pas raison malheureusement sur
ces sur ses propos
peur de l'immigration la peur de l'autre
et très activé par le rassemblement
national par d'autres parce que je pense
que les propos qui sont tenus très
agressifs de sur une partie de
l'échiquier politique fait que les gens
aujourd'hui
ne sont pas sereins ne sont pas rassurés
les crises effectivement ce parti
prospère sur les crises je pense qu'une
partie de la classe politique a un peu
de mal aujourd'hui à rassurer la société
et faire en sorte que c'est
c'était simpliste et populistes encore
une fois
nos prospèrent pas donc il faut
continuer d'arracher à trouver des
solutions sécurisées
encore une fois moi je soutiens
mon collègue Bouillard qui qui a fait
face à des insultes mais faut-il
alimenter
ce type d'émission la France insoumise
qui tout à fait et je pense à la France
insoumise faut-il se prêter au jeu de
ces petites phrases
de l'agitation de toutes ces peurs je
pense que il faut aujourd'hui pouvoir
rassurer les Français nous avons des
crises nous arrivons à les passer à les
surmonter passe en casse malheureusement
mais tout est fait pour essayer de faire
en sorte que demain soit meilleur merci
Nathalie
c'est à Bordeaux carburant combien ça va
nous coûter c'est la Une de Sud-Ouest
aujourd'hui merci beaucoup de je vais
faire ça merci Nathalie Delattre et
votre proposition de restera donc
examinée cet après-midi dans les
mythiques du Sénat merci beaucoup
d'avoir été avec nous bonne journée à
vous